the more voluntary unhappiness and pain
you embrace the less the involuntary
stuff hurts
[Music]
it's our focus on happiness making us
unhappy Aaron would you start us off
hmm
yeah
my worry with this panel is we might
agree on too much so maybe I'll try and
create some desensis for me the issue
isn't that we are pursuing happiness but
rather that we constantly seek to evade
unhappiness I think there is basically a
sort of pyramid upon which you would
want to build happiness contentment the
first is meeting one's personal needs
shelter food
um Access to Health Care
on top of that you would want to
see some projects in your life being
fulfilled self-actualization and whatnot
and furthermore on top of that you'd
want a sense of obligation and service
to other people now I think unhappiness
comes in when any of those three things
are missing so this idea and it could be
quite a reactionary one I think of well
we just need a little bit more pain and
misery in life and actually that will do
us all the world of good I think that's
mistaken whereas my mother's generation
used to say as I was growing up in the
1990s what we need is a good War uh very
reactionary sort of thatcherite
statement you'd hear a lot then less so
now thankfully I don't think that would
make anybody more happy where I do think
we're failing though as I said as at the
beginning is that we have a society now
which constantly seeks to evade
unhappiness there's a wonderful stoical
aphorism which essentially states that
the more voluntary unhappiness and pain
you embrace the less the involuntary
stuff hurts so the next time you have to
get up at 5am in the morning to take
your kids to foot or you have to do
something at work which you really don't
want to just remember it's probably in
the long term going to make you happy
finally that's true as long as you want
to do it that's the key thing uh finally
I would say we have a a pandemic an
epidemic in this in this country in our
societies of loneliness and Solitude and
for me what is the opposite of
of happiness and I think that's a good
way of understanding what real happiness
is I'd say two words boredom and being
alone
and when I say boredom people say oh god
look sometimes boredom is good it's you
don't have to be on your phone and
distracts all the time I don't mean that
I mean being bored in one's life I think
is deeply detrimental to happiness and I
think that sense of not really having
social obligations and being in touch
with others again is a real real problem
and sadly we have a society which is
built precisely on these two things
um liberal capitalism does lots of good
things it helps us meet some of those
essential needs we haven't never had
such extraordinary social abundance
but at the same time we're missing out
on some of the sort of connective social
tissue that actually has been the
Mainstay of our civilization our
societies not just for us twelve
thousand years of Agriculture for the
last two hundred thousand years since
the birth of our species and it's only
really in the last sort of 50 to 100
years those are beginning to erode and
so that sense that actually we're more
and more unhappy uh I don't think is
inaccurate but I don't think the problem
is the pursuit of happiness I think it's
the constant evasion of unhappiness
sometimes if you choose to be unhappy
even briefly it can be good for you
so there is a bold statement choose
unhappiness at least in some
circumstances thank you Aaron for that
starting point Paul could I Turn to You
for Your three-minute pitch
yeah most of what he just said
most of what he just said not all of
what he said so
um I distinguish between being alone and
feeling lonely
um I think that's important we've had an
epidemic of loneliness
not necessarily being alone right and we
we see loneliness rates
um reported loneliness rates highest
much younger people often people think
about loneliness as being older because
they are alone actually young people
connected on social media often feel
lonely
so completely agree uh that it's a
fundamental determinant of people's
happiness
um
people make all sorts of mistakes about
what's going to make them feel good
keeps me a job really
um sort of mocking people for their
stupidity
um but none of us really unless we're
masochistic
well let's leave that category to one
side or actively sort out things that we
know for sure would make us feel worse
as I say we make all sorts of mistakes
we get it wrong all over time
and the reason I say that is because I
have a very inclusive definition of
Happiness a lot obviously will turn on
what we mean by happiness and it was set
up at the beginning as almost like a
choice between happiness and purpose the
subtitle of my book which you thankfully
read out is finding pleasure and purpose
in everyday life happiness for me
includes the you dymonic as well as the
headonic it is a sense of feeling like
what you do has a point is Meaningful
isn't boring I think that's absolutely
right boredom boredom is awful and
without the risk of boring you
by talking for too much longer
of course the fundamental part of the
human condition is survival
but it ain't survival just to any end
we're motivated to survive we have
incentives to survive if we're motivated
to feel good in doing so and as I say
leaving masochism to one side
um then we are a species that has sought
to
with all sorts of mistakes and all sorts
of Errors maximize happiness in one form
or another
thanks very much indeed Paul succinctly
put and giving us plenty to think about
and that term purpose is something we'll
come back to later in the discussion but
not immediately because I want to make
sure that we have this uh first take in
terms of what we're actually talking
about Joanna cavena is going to lead us
on on that thank you Rana
um so I agree yeah dangerously quite a
lot with both of my fellow this is
making me very unhappy or disagree yeah
sorry but I mean I it's such an
interesting word happiness because we
all kind of agree that it's a good thing
well apart from Aaron's arguing that it
may not be in some settings and if I
wish you all a happy weekend that's
meant to be a sort of nice thing but as
Paul was saying there's always different
meanings of course in intrinsics that
are you a hedonist or a euda monist or
and if I mean it's nice the idea that
you combine them because I always think
otherwise you know if you said a happy
weekend and then you put them to the two
groups together you know the euda
monitor will want to be sort of virtuous
and the Headless wants to go and get
smashed and actually they're both having
a really difficult time at that point so
it's good to find a way I think to
combine and I was thinking about this in
terms of uh
uh there's a good title to a no uh
collection of short stories by David
Foster Wallace which is a supposedly fun
thing I'll never do again and I quite
like that idea how many supposedly fun
things have we done and maybe in a sense
as we gain knowledge in life part of
that is gaining a sense of what these
supposedly fun things are for each one
of us and kind of knocking them off the
list and and learning the things that we
actually enjoy and the other thing is as
Aaron was saying I mean this quote you
mentioned Rana about
Alexander Pope on oh happiness our
beings end and aim that's that's a kind
of piece of sort of optimism Philosophy
from the 18th century and Pope says
don't worry everyone be happy because
God has got this and whatever is is
right and just kind of chill and even
within the 18th century in a very
religious time there's a huge amount of
Kickback to that I mean Voltaire says
what on Earth are you talking about you
know there's just been a terrible
earthquake in Lisbon you know nearly 50
000 people have died and you're talking
about General happiness and he says
you're making kind of General happiness
you know this sort of ultimate goal of
all this dire unhappiness I mean how
dare you so there's a kind of debate
there about how can
how can Alexander Pope be so relaxed in
the face of a sort of General suffering
as well so I think I'm going to agree
really that that reality is very complex
our lives are very
mysterious and I think single definition
terms may not Define them entirely and
the philosopher William James talks
about this he actually says if you try
to measure the disc the kind of amazing
continuity of experience with a single
discontinuous word then it's a bit like
if you try to fish up water with a net
you're going to kind of lose all the
interests and everything that's good
about life so I guess William James
would say happiness is a net and our
lives are water and so this kind of sort
of single idea will never fully
Encompass them
thank you Joe and I love that line that
happiness is a net and if there's anyone
called Annette here in the audience
please do uh put your hand forward and
we'll find out whether that really is
true or not
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas